starting today more than 30 million
Americans who rely on federal help to
buy food will no longer receive extra
pandemic error benefits low-income
families in more than 30 States who take
part in snap the supplemental nutrition
assistance program will see their
monthly benefits cut by at least one
hundred dollars and the cost of food is
still on the rise Nancy Chen spoke to
some of those people about what this
means for them
do you think you'll be visiting more
food banks like this oh yes as boost to
SNAP benefits end retired Airline
service agent George cappella says he's
now left figuring out how to put food on
the table you have to make more make up
for it somewhere and hopefully you can
the additional assistance went into
effect about three years ago during the
pandemic and helped keep 4.2 million
Americans out of poverty but starting
today some 30 million people relying on
the federal food stamp program will see
their monthly benefits shrink by at
least 95 dollars and potentially more
than 250 for others we anticipate a
really significant uptick in the number
of people who are going to visit us in
the coming weeks Leslie Gordon is the
president and CEO of food bank for New
York City and says families already have
few options with food prices climbing
more than 11 percent from just a year
ago I never thought in my wildest dreams
that we would see an increase of almost
a double the amount of people who are
visiting our agency partners on the
ground for food
Banks across the country are bracing for
the increased demand from Indiana to
Texas to California in Seattle Leticia
Brito says she and her son may soon not
have enough food what is really worrying
me right now is having a cut down on the
food that I'm gonna have to buy so I can
have enough money to pay my rent
okay
to help offset costs experts recommend
reaching out to your state Human
Services Agency in claiming all
allowable deductions also look into the
women infants and children program or
WIC anti-hunger Advocates say it's an
underutilized program that snap
recipients automatically qualify for and
this affects so many families it's good
to know that there is some kind of
option thank you Nancy